They good?
they're good
hey
you have to see this
amazing right
it's beautiful
Cool
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my marvel agents of
shield season 7 finale video
there were a bunch of marvel phase 4
easter eggs avengers end game
the spider-man far from home post credit
scene with agents of sword and nick
fury's big space station
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing an amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with sword in the marvel
cinematic universe going forward the
organization
so obviously spoiler warning for
everything that happened on agents of
shield we'll also be talking about
everything that's going on in the marvel
cinematic universe during marvel phase
four as well
we'll just do top 10 in avengers
easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 modoc there was
a big story that the agents of shield
producers told about how
originally they had intended to use
modok is the main villain for season
seven
they said that they started writing
episodes based on that but then marvel
came back and retracted their permission
and said no you can't use
modok because we're going to be using
him in the mcu movies
so the big question now is is where's
modok going to show up in the mcu
i did a video a while ago about ant-man
3. there was a story about an early
version of a script where modoc was
going to be the main villain of that
movie and he was going to be the person
with aim
behind sunny birch with the billions of
dollars that wanted hank pym's quantum
technology
no idea if that survived to the new
version of the movie they're working on
ant-man 3 right now it's a new
screenwriter so the script is going to
be different they're rumors that they're
going to use the young avengers
characters and set up that team during
the movie now because you have cassie
lang's stature and she's just one of the
core
young avengers characters that they have
during marvel phase four some of the
other new ones will show up on the
disney plus series too
but number 9 the quantum realm time
travel and alternate realities this is
where we get into the avengers end game
connections and really hardcore mcu
easter eggs
we find out that fitz has been using the
quantum realm ant-man style to travel
through time and travel between
different realities this whole season
has been the team
jumping through time but it was revealed
at the end of the season that the
quantum realm was responsible for a lot
of these twists
so just like in avengers end game fitz
is jumping between
different realities to save the day the
way they're using the quantum realm is a
little bit different than the way they
use it during avengers end game
they refine some of the rules of time
travel so the way they explain it
is the quote-unquote time stream
explainer of time travel
the way they talk about it in the
episode is that you throw a bunch of
sticks into a river
the river isn't affected unless you
throw in too many sticks
and the timelines start to branch off so
there were a couple branch timelines
this season that i'll talk about in a
second
during avengers end game the reason for
their branch timelines were because they
were stealing infinity stones and the
infinity stones control the flow of time
so they were just making much
bigger changes to the timeline at least
temporarily until captain america took
the stones back
this whole twist jumping between
different realities traveling through
time is also something they're going to
be doing on the loki
series for disney plus the big avengers
endgame spin-off that version of loki
that escaped with the tesseract
that's not going to premiere till spring
next year we probably won't get a
trailer for that for a while but we'll
get some more previews as they go back
to start filming really soon
the whole reason that the shield team
needed to jump between a couple
different realities
is because they needed someone who was
dead in the main timeline
so they needed to pluck them from an
alternate timeline where they were still
alive
that wound up being quake's secret
sister who was also an inhuman with
vastly different powers
she was super op they needed her to
defeat the chronicoms who were the main
villains of the season
but number eight deke if you don't
remember is fitz and simmons grandson
effectively
he came from a future timeline that
doesn't exist anymore so he was sort of
existing out of time and place kind of
like captain america
he volunteers to stay behind in the
branch timeline the alternate reality so
that the shield team can go back and
they can close the window
that's the original 80s timeline where
he wound up being a rock god pop star
but shield had been destroyed in that
timeline
so because everybody gets their happy
ending he actually does get a version of
a happy ending in that 80s timeline
the government came to him and asked him
to lead a new shield team
so in that timeline he becomes the new
version of nick fury
they got way crazier with time travel
than they did during avengers end game
so if you thought it was complicated
during end game it got way more
complicated during agents of shield
the number seven the avengers
endgame thanos easter egg
so at the end of avengers end game
thanos brings his ship
from 2014 and all of his armies forward
in time to 2023 through the quantum
realm all the villains all the shield
agents do the exact same thing they each
have their own separate armies that they
bring through the quantum realm
to present day at earth to have their
big final battle
number six there were a bunch of reveals
about quake's secret sister who's also
an inhuman
if you don't know who she is her name is
cora in the original main timeline she
had wound up killing herself
so that's why we'd never seen her till
now so that's where the alternate
timeline came in
fitz goes to the alternate timeline so
that they can pluck her where she's
still alive
eventually she winds up helping the
shield agents use her god tier powers to
360 no scope
all the villains while they're stuck in
the lighthouse that's a giant
underground base where they had taken
all their villains
ships to hide out while they were going to
cause this big apocalypse and wipe
everything out but then number five
quake winds up dying sacrificing herself
defeating one of the other main villains
who's this leftover hydra agent
also from an alternate timeline the way
people call it it was a big quake-off
battle
because he had found a way to steal
inhumans powers so that's how he was
using quake's powers against her
but she sacrifices herself to kill him
but then winds up dead in the vacuum of
space for a hot minute till her sister
uses one of her other inhuman powers to
revive her
it's a big easter egg for that guardians
of the galaxy scene where peter quill
and gamora are floating freezing to
death in the vacuum of space for a
little while until they can bring them
back on the ship
the number four fits and simmons
have a secret child
turns out fitz and simmons get their kid
back that they'd been hiding this whole
time to keep them
safe they had a couple other shield
agents and inhumans protecting her
but that child is actually the mother of
deke so even though the deke that we've
known for the past couple of seasons
their friend their grandson is stuck in
the 80s timeline that alternate
timeline they make a couple of jokes
about seeing deak
soon because within about 20-25 years
he'll wind up being born and they'll
quote unquote see him again
they full-blown retire from shield just
so they can live a normal life and just
be a family with their daughter so
number three
the one year later time jump so this is
now after the ending of avengers end
game
so things have chilled out a little bit
there haven't been any giant space
battles in a hot minute you have to
imagine that a lot of this is
overlapping with the avengers end game
ending so you have
a lot of really crazy stuff happening
during that five-year time jump then you
have the big final battle with thanos in
avengers end game
then even though things got a little
crazy during spider-man far from home
after the end of avengers end game for
the most part there isn't any giant
huge cosmic stuff happening we find out
that may is actually a professor now
at quote-unquote coulson university
which i guess is just the internal
shield training program there's another
inhuman character from earlier this
season and last season that shows up and
is one of her students number two
they reveal that mack is now the new
official nick fury of shield he's even
wearing a nip fury trench coat
that's planetside so shield is still
operating
after avengers end game in present day
but they're mostly focused with threats
on planet earth that's why nick fury as
revealed in the spider-man far from home
post-credit scene is on the sword space
station because he's focused more on
threats from outer space
bigger cosmic threats max sends colson a
gift which winds up being
a rebuilt version of lola which is a big
callback to the very beginning
agents of shield episode 1 the pilot
there's a very men in black style scene
where the car takes off but then it
changes colors
it transforms and he flies away just
like coulson in the comics
then number one the big agents of sword
marvel phase four
ending scene so quake is revealed to be
on the zephyr three ship
in deep space with her sister and susa
who they've kept from the agent carter
timeline they didn't bother to take him
back to the 1940s
they say they're entering a nebula and
they're just looking at it like wow this
is so cool
getting ready to go visit some new race
the producers were talking about in the
past how earlier on the show's run
before marvel got the rights back to the
x-men characters
they had wanted to do a big agents of
sword storyline legit inside
earlier seasons but because sword is an
organization technically belonged to fox
because it debuted in the x-men comics
they kept getting shut down on their
sword story lines but now that that's
not the case marvel has the rights to
all the x-men characters back from fox
that final scene with quake is meant to
be a version of what they had originally
planned to do
with sword as an organization the way
that quake talks about it she makes a
reference to astro
ambassadors so think about it in a very
star trek first contact kind of way
going out to visit new space based races
the whole thing was sword during marvel
phase four as you saw during that nick
fury spider-man far from home
post-credits scene is actually going to
continue
i think maybe in falcon and winter
soldier definitely for sure during the
wandavision series because of all the
set photos that we've seen
with the sword logos also a big callback
to avengers infinity war when nick fury
pulls out captain marvel's pager
on the back of this prop it actually
reads
sword so they were actually setting up
sword as an organization in the mcu
a long time ago so if there any other
big marvel phase 4 or avengers easter
eggs that you spotted during the episode
that i didn't include in the video just
write them below in the comments
and let me know where do you want these
characters to show up next
right now i'm working on a new
spider-man tom holland video that should
post later today so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel
you should see that video when it posts
there'll be trailers for falcon and
winter soldier in Wandavision pretty
soon also for the mandalorian season 2
so there's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up
will you wait for everything click here
for the avengers Wandavision trailer and
click here
for the avengers falcon and winter
soldier trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!